imaginemos que aquí tenemos nuestra
función efe y nos preguntamos a qué
valor parece que nos estamos acercando
si x se acerca a 2 entonces qué valor
parece que va a tomar la función en 2 y
lo hacemos desde la izquierda desde
números que son más chicos que 2
entonces lo que estaría pasando es que
nos estaríamos acercando a 2 y quizás
tomaríamos 1.5 luego 1.9 1.999 nos vamos
acercando a 2 de manera que sólo
consideramos valores que son más chicos
que 2 entonces qué está pasando por acá
pues ese de 1 está por aquí y este de
1.5 está por acá y todos los valores
parece que se están acercando a este
valor parece que nos estamos acercando
aquí a 5 y la forma en la que escribimos
esto cuando nos acercamos a un número
por valores que son más chicos que el
número la forma en la que lo escribimos
es decimos
que el límite cuando x tiende a 2 y
ponemos aquí un pequeño menos este 2 no
es este menos no significa que esté 12
negativo no nos estamos acercando a
menos 2 nos estamos acercando a 2 pero
lo estamos haciendo desde la izquierda
desde números más chicos que 2 y
entonces lo que diríamos es que el
límite por la izquierda de fx cuando x
tiende a 2 desde números más chicos que
2 es igual a 5 parece que nos acercamos
a 5 y podríamos hacer la pregunta
completamente análoga de qué sucede si
nos acercamos a 2 pero ahora desde la
derecha entonces ahora vendíamos desde
32.5 2.1 2.0 12.000 201 cada vez nos
acercamos más a 2 entonces está aquí y
entonces qué pasa pues f 3 está aquí es
el 2.5 parece estar por acá ese de 2.01
quizás esté por aquí pero todos los
valores parecen acercarse a un 2 y la
forma en la que escribimos esto es que
el límite de ese de x cuando x tiende a
2 pero ahora desde números más grandes
que todos poniendo un pequeño signo
positivo al lado de este 2
esto es igual a 1 y de hecho la función
no toma ninguno de estos dos valores no
toma ni 5 ni 1 la función aquí vale 9
porque aquí tenemos una discontinuidad
exacto así que de hecho el límite
para que el límite cuando s de x se
acerque a un valor cuando x acerque a un
valor exista tienen que existir estos
dos números y tienen que coincidir en
este caso el límite por la izquierda el
límite de fx cuando x tiende a 2 desde
los negativos o desde la izquierda no
coincide con el límite
no coincide con el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a 2 desde los positivos así que
en este caso y déjenme lo anoto en este
caso el límite cuando x tiende a 2 en
general o sea desde cualquier dirección
de fx
en este caso el límite cuando x tiende a
2 de fx no existe y la razón por la cual
no existe es para que existiera estos
dos límites unilaterales tendrían que
haber sido el mismo por ejemplo
qué pasaría si nos preguntáramos por el
límite
el límite cuando x tiende a 4 de f de x
esto cuánto sería pues veamos hagamos
exactamente el mismo ejercicio primero
nos acercamos desde la izquierda desde
los negativos entonces
efe de 3.5 está más o menos por aquí s
de 3.7 estará por acá s 3.9 está por
aquí y todos los valores parece que se
acercan a este valor de menos 5 así que
por un lado tendría que el límite cuando
x tiende a 4 desde los negativos desde
la izquierda desde números más chicos
que 4 el límite de fx cuando x tiende a
4 desde la izquierda sería igual a menos
y
si nos acercamos por la derecha es decir
ahora quiero calcular el límite cuando x
tiende a 4 pero desde la derecha desde
los positivos el límite de fx pues
veamos qué pasa f 5 está aquí efe 4.5
está por acá ese de 4.1 está por aquí
entonces cada vez nos volvemos a acercar
a este valor de menos 5
de hecho la función está definida en 4
pero aún así el límite como vimos en
este caso podría no coincidir con el
valor de la función ahora bien como
estos dos límites existen y son iguales
este límite es igual a este límite
entonces puedo afirmar que el límite
cuando x tiende a 4 de fx es igual a
menos 5 veamos un par de ejemplos más
bien entonces vamos a considerar ahora
esta función ésta que esta gráfica de
aquí es nuestra nueva f y hagamos el
mismo ejercicio vamos a empezar
preguntándonos cuál es el límite el
límite cuando x se acerca a 8 desde los
negativos desde la dirección negativa o
desde números más chicos que 8 el límite
de fx cuando x tiende a 8 desde la
izquierda a cuánto es esto igual y los
invito a detener el vídeo y tratar de
descubrirlo por ustedes mismos pero
bueno entonces si nos acercamos a 8 por
la izquierda nos estamos acercando a 8
por números más chicos y entonces veamos
aquí tenemos ese 7 aquí tenemos a efe de
7.5 cada vez parece que nos estamos
acercando a este valor parece que nos
estamos acercando al valor 3 así que
podría decir que el límite cuando x
tiende a 8 desde los negativos de fx es
igual a 3
y que hay que hay del límite el límite
cuando x tiende a 8 desde los positivos
desde números más grandes que 8 el
límite de ese x cuando x tiende a 8
desde los positivos a cuánto es igual
pues mismo ejercicio ahora nos acercamos
desde la derecha y entonces aquí tenemos
f9 efe de 8.5 es de 8.1 parece que nos
estamos acercando a este valor parece
que cada vez nos acercamos al valor 1 y
de nuevo como estos dos límites no
coinciden entonces afirmó que el límite
el límite en cual el límite general el
límite cuando x se acerca a 8 desde
cualquier dirección
de fx
no existe
no existe este límite porque los límites
unilaterales son distintos este 3 es
claramente distinto a este 1 un último
ejemplo y en este de hecho nos están
haciendo una especie de pregunta nos
dicen la función s esta gráfica de abajo
el valor del límite unilateral el límite
cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
dirección negativa desde la izquierda de
fx parece ser y nos preguntan cuánto
parece ser este límite así que hagamos
exactamente el mismo ejercicio que
veníamos haciendo veamos nos queremos
acercar a menos 2 donde noten que la
función no está definida así que veamos
efe de menos 4 está por aquí entonces
ese de menos 4 se acerca a este valor
efe - 3 está por acá este menos 3 está
aquí efe de menos 2.1 está ahí y
entonces corresponde más o menos este
valor todos los valores parecen
acercarse a 4 así que me atrevería a
decir que éste
parece ser 4 el límite cuando x tiende a
menos 2 desde la izquierda de fx parece
ser 4 también nos podríamos preguntar
cuánto vale el límite cuando x se acerca
a menos 2 desde los positivos desde la
derecha y efe de 0 parece estar de nuevo
por aquí s de menos 1 está por acá
parece coincidir con ese de menos 3 y
efe de menos 1.99 parece estar por ahí
entonces de nuevo parece que el límite
cuando x tiende a menos 2 desde la
dirección positiva o desde la derecha
parece ser también 4 ahora como este
límite unilateral el límite por la
derecha y el límite por la izquierda
coinciden los dos valen 4
puedo afirmar que el límite cuando x
tiende a menos 2 desde cualquier
dirección el límite general
de fx es igual a 4 y ya acabamos